sinon j'aime la musique et fils à son
rôle et à monsieur marc le fur
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre nous sommes en pleine
crise agricole
cette crise s'aggraver les choses vont
extrêmement vite
cette crise se traduit par des drames
individuels familiaux par l'effondrement
d'un certain nombre de filières
agricoles mais ce sont aussi des
territoires qui se sentent aujourd'hui
menacés
cela vaut pour bien des territoires de
france et cela revêt une acuité toute
particulière en bretagne
c'est pour ça que les élus bretons toute
sensibilité rassemblés ont décidé de se
retrouver en masse samedi prochain à 15h
à loudéac au coeur de la bretagne ce
rassemblement associera toutes les
tendances syndicales
la fnsea le cnj a mais aussi la
coordination rurale où la confédération
paysanne
monsieur le premier ministre il faut que
vous entendiez cet appel de loudéac
cet appel qui vous demandent de décréter
l'état d'urgence agricole pour nos
territoires il n'y a pas de plan b si
l'agriculture et l'agroalimentaire
s'effondre il n'y a pas de solution de
remplacement à horizon immédiat
aujourd'hui l'europe ne bouge pas la
parole de la france des plus entendu on
l'a pu le constater hier mais il ya des
choses monsieur le premier ministre qui
ne dépendent que de nous que de nous la
baisse des impôts conditions de la
compétitivité
ça ne dépend que de nous la baisse des
charges conditions de la compétitivité
contraintes administratives conditions
de la compétitivité
ça ne dépend que de nous monsieur le
premier ministre c'est pour cela que
samedi ce qui se réuniront en masse à
loudéac vous demanderont un rendez vous
très solennellement pour que nous
puissions traiter avec vous des sujets
qui relèvent de votre compétence
ils attendent désormais de vous des
décisions ils attendent désormais pour
ce rendez vous a lieu et une date
merci la parole est à monsieur stéphane
le foll ministre de l'agriculture de
l'agroalimentaire et de la forêt et on
écoute sa réponse s'il vous plaît
monsieur le député le fur
chacun a bien compris dans votre
question l'intérêt que vous portez à
l'agriculture de manière générale et à
l'agriculture bretonne de manière
particulière ce qui est le cas de tout
le monde
vous avez évoqué un certain nombre de
sujets et je vais y revenir
en particulier la question européenne
sur lequel vous avez dit des choses qui
ne sont pas exacts si l'europe a saisi
le dossier en septembre
c'est à la demande de la france si
l'europe a discuté pendant deux heures
et demie hier en conseil agricole c'est
à la demande de la france
et si le commissaire européen change
d'avis sur l'analyse de la crise c'est à
la demande de la france
vous avez évoqué le pacte et d'urgence
que j'ai noté l'opposition souhaite à
une déclaration d'état d'urgence avec un
certain nombre de points
vous avez évoqué le moratoire sur la
sueur transposition des normes
parfaitement exact moratoire appliquée
depuis 2012 et s'il ya des normes
aujourd'hui c'est celle que vous aviez
vous même adopté avec ne l'aviez pas
changé vous auriez pu le faire vous avez
évoqué la baisse des charges monsieur le
fur je voudrais rappeler que quand nous
sommes arrivés la baisse des charges
dans l'agriculture était liée aux
exonérations de françois fillon elle
était autour de 600 millions d'euros
aujourd'hui pour l'agriculture la baisse
des charges c'est 1,9 milliard d'euros
si vous aviez pu vous auriez dû faire
monsieur le fluo vous avez ensuite
évoqué des questions d'étiquetage vrais
sujets je me rappelle ou parlement
européen en 2010 que votre groupe ppe a
voté contre
l'étiquetage dans les produits
transformés
et qu'à la même époque madame renato
chômeurs qui est votre famille politique
il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
traçabilité quand gladys ville motte
socialistes et travaillistes avaient dit
que c'était une erreur fondamentale
chacun assume ses responsabilités chacun
a devant les agriculteurs
derrière sa vie